in this video I want to talk a little
bit about how much ATP we get from
breaking down one glucose molecule if
we're going to break down a glucose
molecule how much ATP will we get or how
much energy will we get we break down
one glucose molecule we're going to
start off with glycolysis if you recall
glycolysis breaks glucose down into
three different end and we get three
different products we break the actual
glucose the six carbon molecule into two
three carbon pyruvates
we also net two ATP we invest two we
make four so the net of two ATP and we
make two nadh --is for every one glucose
because the each we get one NADH from
each glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate but
since there are two of them we make two
NADH s if any that is unclear to go back
and watch the glycolysis videos now NADH
and ATP well are basically valued at a
particular amount of energy this
pyruvate though can be further broken
down so pyruvate where does pyruvate go
assuming we have assuming an oxidative
it or an oxygen-rich environment right
if we have oxygen available it'll go
through aerobic respiration so this is
if if there's oxygen available pyruvate
will go to the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex to prepare for the Krebs cycle
now each pyruvate in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex is converted to an
acetyl co a so one pyruvate turns into
one acetyl co a and in that reaction we
create one NADH so how many would we get
for each glucose well if we have for
each pyruvate we're getting one there
are two pyruvates that are coming from
one glucose molecule so we would just
double those numbers we get two acetyl
co ways and two NADH is from the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex now what
happens now this NADH right over these
NADH s here are valued right they have a
particular energy value with this acetyl
go away you can go through the Krebs
cycle so it can be further broken down
so these are Co Co ways go to the kreb
cycle for each of Co Co a we create a
given number of nadh fadh2 is in a GTP
if you recall there's one step in which
we create a GTP so for each acidic away
that goes to
the kreb cycle we get one GTP there's
also only one reaction that creates an
fadh2 how many reactions that are
actually within the krebs cycle create
nadh they're actually three of them so
that's for each acetyl co a that goes to
the krebs cycle but what about for each
glucose well again if if each glucose
broke down into the two pyruvates and
those two pyruvates each one gives you
one acetyl co a s that means you have
two acetyl COAS
so two acetyl coa is you would just
double all these numbers for each bucco
so you would get six NADH s from the
prep cycle to fadh2 s and two GTP's so
now we're going to calculate how much we
energy we get from one glucose molecule
so how many NADH is do we get from the
Krebs cycle and pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex we have two nadh is here and six
NADH is here so that's actually going to
be eight NADH is you'll notice that I
wrote NADH twice and I'll get to that in
just a second how many FIDH do we have -
how many GTP's - now glycolysis we had
two ATP's and we had two NADH is you
might be wondering why I wrote to nad
ages these two NADH is separately this
is very very important because
glycolysis occurs in the cytosol while
these two pathways both occur in the
mitochondrial matrix okay now when these
NADH is are created in the mitochondrial
matrix they can go straight to the to
the electron transport chain which is
which happens along the inner membrane
of the mitochondria if I drew it out
like this right
the etc' is along this membrane okay
the electron transport chain which we'll
talk about in future videos but any of
the NADH s that are made in here in the
mitochondrial matrix they can go
straight to the lechon transport chain
because the membrane is right there but
NADH is that are made
out in the cell in the cytosol I do that
really really big country but if these
NADH is right are made in the cytoplasm
of the cytosol so these are named eh is
when they're made the NADH these any DHS
cannot cross these membranes okay they
cannot cross and get into the
mitochondrial membrane so the way they
get in to the to the way they get their
value into the mitochondria is they have
to under their to go in through a
shuttle mechanism so there are actually
two different shuttle mechanisms so I'll
explain that in a further video actually
or but for now let's just do the energy
calculation so all these NADH is that
were made in the PV H or the Krebs cycle
they're going to be worth 2.5 ATP
excellent 2.5 ATP these fadh2s each is
going to be worth 1.5 ATP gtp is are
going to be worth 1 ATP and ATP is of
course are worth each are worth 1 ATP
these nadh is from glycolysis can
actually write that here so i can note
that so these are coming from glycolysis
and these are coming from the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex and the Krebs
cycle these ones from glycolysis they
can be worth 2.5 or 1.5 depending on
which shuttle mechanism they enter the
mitochondria by okay so this or here
this or is all right over here based on
which shuttle mechanism is used to
transport NADH is value into the
mitochondrion
okay so if it was I'll actually just
mention them here
the male ate aspartate shuttle would
cause it to be worth 2.5 ATP and the
glycerol phosphate shuttle would cause
it to be worth 1.5 ATP I'll talk more
about this in another video but let's
just do the calculation for now so 2
times 1.5 would be 3 2 x 2.5 would be 5
so that would be the 3.5 ATP from those
for those uh
nadh is there this 8 x 2.5 that'll
actually be 20 excuse me these two
fadh2s each one is worth 1.5 so that's 3
ATP the GTP is there's two of them and
the ATP's is two of those so if you
total this up to 2 is 4 plus 3 is 7 27
27 plus 3 is 30 so we either have 30 or
32 ATP from one glucose molecule okay
so 30 if we if those NADH is going to
the cholesterol fall Space Shuttle 32 if
they go into the melee aspartate shuttle
and again I'll talk about that in
another video but this is basically how
you calculate the amount of energy that
you would get from one glucose molecule
I hope that was helpful thanks for
watching